こんにちはスティーブ今日ここで
日本語について話したいと思い
ます。私
はスティーブの簡単な紹介と呼ぶさまざまな言語でシリーズをやろうと
思っています。これはスティーブの簡単な日本語の紹介
です。
特に
本を開い
て、発音の詳細な説明がいっぱい
で、日本語の場合は、
私が理解できなかったピッチについて話し、人々がハングアップする場合は特に、新しい言語に近づくと、非常に多くの人が一種の不安攻撃をします
日本語の違いについて
簡単に紹介します
日本語は明らか
に英語に関連する言語ではないので、フランス語のよう
な言語を言うよりも日本語の構造に慣れるのに時間がかかります
日本語は実際には
英語よりも音が少ないので、多くの単語が同じように聞こえるという難しさにすぐに遭遇するでしょうが、それはこれらの1つ
です あなたが慣れ親しんでいる
ので、動詞から始めて、動詞、名詞、形容詞
、動詞、名詞の原因と目的の観点から言語にアプローチするのが好き
な場合、言語の残りの部分が進んでいることを理解すれば、他のいくつかのことになるかもしれません
日本語で問題ないのは、カタカナヒラガナと漢字の3つ
を学ぶ必要があるため、ライティングシステムです。
ヒラガナから
始めることをお勧めします。ヒラガナと平行するカタカナにあまり時間をかけないでください。
でも
、漢字が
読めるようになると新聞や雑誌の本などが読める
ようになるので、高いレベルの習熟度を達成するために、日本語と一緒にいることを知りたい場合は、漢字の国を学ぶように努力してください。 現在
、日本語の動詞は非常に簡単に言え
ば、注意しなければならないことがいくつかあります。
単純な形式
があり、intを取得する前のすべての動詞の単純な形式ではありません。
o
礼儀正しさの問題は大丈夫なので、
アキムは行くことができます。私は行くことができます。
彼は行くこと
ができます。
私たちをハケムして、
e qu eChemaの短い形があります
それは同じように行くことができますチベットああ
トップ私たちが食べる私はそれらすべてを通過するつもり
はありません
シンプルで長い
形があり、それらを同じように使用でき
、ある単語がいつ使用されるか、別の単語が使用されるかを心配する必要はありませ
ん。言語に十分に触れるまで、
正しく理解できないからです。
十分な露出があれば、自然
に正しく使用できるようになります。最終的には、過去形を表現するために
人々が今
何を言っているかに関係なく、それらを交換して使用できるかどうかは問題ではありませ
ん。 行く
アキム私たちが鍵になるマルタマルタは
過去形です
taberuタビーマスは彼に私たちのものを教えてくれます今
私たちは過去形になっています今再び
それの単純な形が
ありますキーマーストンの代わりにあなたは私のものを上に運ぶ代わりにそれが行われたと言うことができます
通常は形式的ではありませんが、
実際には同じ意味で使用されてい
ます。現在、日本語の未来
は英語とは少し異なります。
明日はestar estar aqui
masなので、私が研究するeキーワード
は将来あなたが機能する可能性があります。
明日はダラムと同じではない
か、ショーと同じになる可能性が高いので、おそらくタイプの未来のような未来の形を持って
いますが、私は数学を勉強していると言うことも
できます。
行く可能性が高いショーすべてが行く可能性がありますそれは
非常に単純な未来です動詞の基本的な
概念には十分ですそれから私たち
は日本語
の
名詞を取得します なれ  1冊の本多くの
本フェミニンな男性の本はありませ
んが、そうです家カルマは車ですが
、文脈から言うと、ホーン税と言えば
、多くの本の多くの連絡先を意味し、
カウンターと呼ばれるものがありますが、 私はいつも、
1つの家が1つのポイントから始まることを意味するextortsを使用します。
本の絆のためのカウンターが
何であるかわかりません。
あなたがEEGに来ないことを知っている
私の1枚の紙は明らか
に動物です
これらはカウンターですが
、一般的なカウンターがあるようにコールワークを食べ
ません私はそれについて心配しません
名詞についての重要なことはあるという
ことです 性別も数も
ありません。文脈から、名詞
について次に話して
いるのは、日本語の多くの人にとって一種のバグベアであり、
粒子と呼ばれるものであるため、一部の言語では、大文字と小文字の
区別が異なります。
日本語の単語の機能あなた この粒子を持っている
ので、彼女が得
たものは、彼女が何であるかを私の神の後に置きます。彼女
が得たものは、
誰かに本を渡した場合の動詞の主題である一種のマーカーです。
それは
私が本を手にした直接の目的語であるということああおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
彼らはいつもと今に付けられていると呼ば
れ、方向を示しているので、
ええ、家から家へ
のキャラは弁護士です-あなたはあなたからのカラではあり
ません実際にはそれほど難しい
概念ではありませ
ん スラヴ語で終わる
ので、
もう一度慣れる必要があります。一度にすべてを覚えようと
しないでください。名詞の後の小さな助詞が
、目的語か
間接目的語かを示します。 何か
の目的のために何かから何かへ
そしてそうbr イース形容詞は通常
、つまみの前
に来
ます。 赤じゃない
こんにちは私は
速い timoniだから、こんにちは、彼女は
走るために月を書いたので、彼女は月曜日に戻ってき
ました。今日の月曜日が何で
あるかを理解するために、今日は何
ですか。
カリバは速い場合はこんにちは
イナアバは速い場合も日本語のことの1つは
常に
t-34がありますそれは2つまたは3つまたは4つの
異なる
方法で物事を言う交換可能な方法を見ました
そしてあなたはあなたが望むものを使うことができ
ます 使用するのはあまり気にしないでください。
アラマは何も
立派ではないので、やはり灘なだばあ、
この日本語の単語の1つは、
この男を見たようにこれらのフィラーフレーズでいっぱいなので、この男は他の男を見ました。
そうだと
すれば、彼らはアラビア語なので、
あなたがこれらを使うことができるので、彼らはあなた
に私に考える時間を与えてくれます。
動詞が
最後に来て、多くの良いことが最後に来て、
非言語の最後に動詞の終わりに
あること丁寧さ
は、外国人として最初は心配し
ないことです。
できるだけ
中立的に話すことで、状況に応じて非常に非公式またはフォーマルになることで快適なレベルを得ることができますが、
それはあなたが言語に
あまり触れずにできることではない
ので、私は それはあなたのものだとは思わない
理論的に
は徐々に慣れなければならないので
、元の
ポイントに戻ってたくさんのリスニングとリーディングを行う
必要がありますが、読むためには
、ヒーター
が高田と日本語の
文字になる書記体系を学ぶ必要があります。 十分な露出と
十分なリスニングとリーディングを
行うことで、その言語を理解し、その
ときに簡単な日本の
文法書や初心者向けの本を手に取っ
てみると、これらの説明の多くに出くわし
ます。
複雑
ですが、文法の観点からは難しい言語ではあり
ません
が、書記体系の問題と、ヨーロッパの言語
とは構造が異なるという事実
により、慣れにくい言語になっています。それだけです。
あなたができる
限り多くのことに自分自身をさらさなければならないより多くの理由とあなたが
苦労することになる初期の段階で話すのに苦労する
ことを心配しないでください leok聞いてくれてありがとう
[音楽]